هذه هي بلده ستوروجوفا التي تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه انها استعاده السيطره عليها في
اول دفعه من البلدات التي استعاد السيطره
عليها بعد الهجوم المضاد هذا المكان حيث
نتواجد الان كان على ما يبدو موقعا للقوات
الروسيه نستطيع مشاهده اثار هذه القوات
التي تركتها في هذا المكان
بقايا الطعام وكذلك بقايا المعدات هذه
المنطقه استعادت القوات الاوكرانيه
السيطره عليها قبل اسبوع فقط من الان وكما
تقول الحقت خسائر بالقوات الروسيه التي
انسحبت الى بلده ماكاريفكا تلك البلده
التي مازال القتال فيها مستمر وخلفت خلفها
بقايا وضحايا كذلك نستطيع ان نسمع اصوات
القصف الذي لا يزال متواصلا هذا احد
الجنود الروس الذين تركوا في هذه الساحه
في ساحه المعركه هنا في هذا المكان في
اطار الهجوم المض الذي ما زال مستمرا في
المنطقه الواقعه جنوبي الا ان القتال ما
زال عنيفا كما تؤكد القوات الاوكرانيه
والقوات الروسيه لا تترك المواقع بسهوله
تحاول ان تقصف هذه البلدات بشكل متواصل
وتحاول ان تعود الى هذه البلدات التي
انسحبت منها جراء الاشتباكات مع القوات
الروسيه هذه الهجمات المضاده تقع هنا
جنوبي دنيتك كما ايضا في منطقه زاكولوجيا
بالاضافه ايضا الى عدد من المحاور حيث
يقول الخبراء ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول
ان تكتشف الثغرات للوصول الى اهداف بعيده
من المناطق التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه الجنوبيه البلاد حسن مسعود
الجزيره